a woman who killed her seven-year-old
son and left his body in the desert will
be spending her life Behind Bars
Samantha Moreno Rodriguez faced her
child's grieving father as she learned
her fate today Victoria Saha was in the
courtroom with what unfolded Victoria
yeah it was an emotional day in court
for a seven-year-old Liam Houston's dad
and family Liam was killed by his mom in
May of 2021 and when his body was found
on a hiking trail police and residents
sprung into action to figure out who
this little boy was and why he was
murdered
Samantha Moreno Rodriguez didn't have
anything to say to the court before
being sentenced but her lawyer did
take a responsibility
for her actions there's a lot of
self-loathing her her actions took the
life of her autistic son seven-year-old
Liam husted but before the worlds knew
anything about Liam he was known as
little Zion a boy whose body was found
by hikers at the mountain springs
Trailhead between Las Vegas and Pahrump
investigations quickly started to figure
out who he was police believe Moreno
Rodriguez traveled from San Jose
California to Las Vegas where she
strangled Liam and left his body in the
desert and drove to Colorado taking
William's life in a matter of minutes
naked lifeless body on the hiking trail
determined to start a new life in
another state as if nothing happened
after an almost two-week Manhunt Moreno
Rodriguez was arrested in Denver while
having breakfast with a man who police
say she met just days before I helped
him
on purpose care and nurturing
this debt became a victim Liam's dad
Nicholas Houston speaking to the judge
as Moreno Rodriguez tried hiding from
our cameras the questions of why and how
a mother could do this to her own son
still haunts him but Moreno Rodriguez
had told investigators while she and
Liam were hiking he fell and started to
scream very loudly and she didn't know
how to stop him why didn't she call me
for help I'm wondering how he suffered
his last day and how scared he must have
been
I had asked Liam's dad for a comment on
the punishment his son's mom received
but he declined Kirsten yeah it's just
so sad thank you Victoria Marina
Rodriguez could be eligible for parole
after 28 years